hey guys house of the Dragon is based on
George R Martin's book Fire and Blood
and now you can listen to it for free
with a notable trial using our link
which you can find in the description of
this video all you have to do is go to
the description click the link sign up
for a free audible trial and choose Fire
and Blood audiobook go and listen to a
complete Targaryen history including the
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free
according to Legend a huntsman once
tracked a lion that was terrorizing his
village all the way to its den
though armed with only a spear the man
managed to kill both the lion and its
mate but spared the Cubs this mercy so
pleased the old gods that they sent a
shaft of sunlight deep into the cave
gleaming golden wall
the hunter became a miner and built a
ring for to guard his new wealth
nobody ever asks what happened to the
cops maybe the gods forgot about them
and they starved maybe there never were
any cops and lions and Hunter doesn't
matter someone found enough gold in that
cave to buy whatever truth he wanted
along with a castle that he'd name after
his new family
constantly Rock
thanks to that gold casterly rock soon
became the largest wealthiest and best
defended Castle in Westeros an army that
struggled up the main approach would
still have to climb thick high and
well-defended walls should they choose
instead to lay Siege the sea helpfully
carved a massive cave beneath the castle
which over time became a private Port
complete with ducks wharfs and shipyards
and so to this day even with all the
gold in Westeros to tent Invaders
constantly Rock
at least not in battle the castle is
sadly All That Remains of its namesake
family the castles according to another
Legend my ancestor land the clever
swindled the castle from them the most
common story is that he found a hidden
cleft in the Rock and snuck into the
castle
at night he whispered threats into
sleeping ears howled in the darkness
planted one brother's Treasures in the
room of another and so forth by the end
of his games the casterlies believed the
demon was Haunting their home and fled
my brother prefers a different version
Bland the clever did find a secret
entrance into the Rock but used it to
have his way with the casterly maidens
eventually the girls gave birth to
golden-haired bastards and the
casterlies had no choice but to accept
their father into the family
in gratitude he changed the family name
to honor himself and House Lannister was
born
the castellis used the gold of the rocks
to become Lords the Lannisters became
Kings
for thousands of years the kingdom of
the rock ruled the westerlands when the
ironborn became a nuisance my ancestor
sailed to the iron islands and returned
with a hundred ironborn hostages
promising to hang one from the rock
every time the ironborn dead radar
Shores the ironborn stayed away well
after 20 or so when the Andals arrived
after sweeping across the rest of
Westeros we invited their sons and
daughters into the Rockers Squires and
caught ladies I don't think we ever had
to hang any of them
finally aegon the Conqueror defeated us
on the field of fire and my ancestor
knelt still little changed but titles
and taxes for when visenia Targaryen saw
the rock she gave thanks that my
ancestor had met aegon in the field even
dragonflame would have washed over the
castle like the waves and left just
ice when disciplining unruly Razzles
most Lords sent armies my father Tywin
only had to send a singer there's no
faster way to Dollar Basil's ambition or
any festive occasion the
[Music]
how's reign of Castamere was an old and
proud house that was slowly sinking back
into the muck their minds had run dry
without gold they turned to a more
common source of wealth
daughters lady Ellen rain was betrothed
to my great uncle but when he fell in
battle lady Ellen sought comfort in his
twin brother's bed beating out the other
woman he promised to marry then the
husband who had shared his Twin's wife
shared his Twin's death on a different
Battlefield lady Ellen flung herself at
the new and married heir to the Rock
but my grandfather Titus was more kitten
than lion
he ran away and told his wife of Lady
Ellen's designs and Lady Ellen soon
found herself married off to Walter and
topic Lord of another failing house the
Reigns and topics should have sunk Into
Obscurity together and they would have
if not for my grandfather becoming Lord
of casterly rock at first the
westerlands laughed with the Laughing
lion as the jovial Titus was called but
when men realized this lion had neither
teeth nor claws he started to laugh at
him
none laughed harder than the rains and
topics
though lady Ellen was no longer welcome
at casterly Rock Titus didn't refuse her
brothers Roger and Reynard Reign not
even when they asked for extravagant
loans
thanks to our family's gold lady Ellen
restored topic Hall to a splendor she
had known since being cast out of our
home
when my grandfather broached the subject
of repayment Rocha and Reynard only
laughed
and soon enough my grandfather was
laughing along with them
then my father Tywin returned from the
war of the nine Penny Kings where he'd
seen how the rest of the Realms
snickered and house last
determined to restore our proper place
my father demanded the immediate
repayment of all deaths to The Rock
or a hostage from those who couldn't pay
Reynard rain merely laughed when he
received the raven
Lord Walter and tarby chose to ride to
casterly rock sure that he could cow
Lord Titus into rescinding my father's
commands
he could have except it wasn't Titus who
met him at the gates but my father who
had Lord Waterman thrown into a dungeon
lady Ellen protested the Reigns
threatened war and finally my
grandfather broke and released Lord
tarbick with an apology no less as if
bathing himself in shame ties us further
forgave all the tarpic deaths to our
house
to celebrate the end of hostilities Lord
Roger feasted Titus at Castamere and the
two Lords proclaimed their friendship
for eternity
my father allowed eternity to last a
year
we summoned the Reigns and topics to
casterly rock to answer for their crimes
they Rose in Revolt exactly as he
expected their Defiance gave him a
pretext to call his banners and ride for
Target Hall and Castamere with an army
behind him he didn't even bother to
inform my grandfather my father's Army
descended on the topic so quickly that
Lord Waldron had no time to gather his
forces and rode against my father with
only his household Knights
soon his head his son's heads and the
heads of any man with tarpic blood
adorned the spears of the Lannister
Vanguard as it marched to Tomic Hall
and their approach lady Ellen topic
closed the gates and sent Ravens to her
brothers at Castamere she assumed they'd
have more than enough time to muster
their armies and break what would be a
long Siege
her father had trouble shares up in a
day
broke down the keep within hours
lady Ellen and her son were crushed in
its fall
when the target forces surrendered
and father put their Castle to the torch
Roger Reign arrived with his army just
in time to see the Flames consuming his
sister's home
he charged my father's Camp hoping
surprise would win out over my father's
great numbers
it didn't with half his men dead on the
field and a crossbowled in his back
Lord Roger fled back to Castamere
the Lannister host arrived at Castamere
three days later like constantly Rock
the seat of house rain had begun as a
mine when the gold gave out the mine
shafts were widened into Halls Galleries
and bed changes deep beneath the Earth
the rain Brothers didn't have the men to
defend the castle walls and retreated
into their underground stronghold
from this relative safety they offered
terms to my father to avoid a long Siege
my father didn't reply instead he
commanded that the mines be sealed with
stone and soil until there was no way in
and no way out
when that was completed it took less
than a day to damn the stream beside the
castle and only two to diverted to the
nearest mine entrance
the rains have taken more than 300 men
women and children into the mines few
guards reported hearing faint screams
and shouts below them one night but come
Dawn the
silent once in
onesie
and now the rain weeps over the Halls
with no one left to hear
on the far western coast of the
continent higher topper Rocky Promontory
overlooking the sunset sea sits casterly
Rock ancestral seat of House Lannister
below it lies lannis Port one of the
great cities of Westeros a center for
trade culture and the great Lannister
Fleet
there are a number of Gold and Silver
Mines in the westerlands making it the
richest region in all of Westeros
one of the most productive Minds Lies
Beneath casterly Rock itself making
House Lannister the wealthiest of all
the noble houses
this allows House Lannister to finance
many Endeavors of other Noble houses
even the king himself has sought credit
from casterly Rock from time to time
we Lannisters claim our descent from the
Andel Invaders and through the female
bloodline land the clever
according to the legend Lan using only
his wits one casterly Rock From The
Noble House of casterly during the Age
of Heroes
the Lannisters reigned as kings of the
rock for thousands of years and worked
to make it the Envy of the rest of the
Seven Kingdoms
our time as kings ended however when
aegon Targaryen otherwise known as aegon
the Conqueror arrived in Westeros with
his army
the last king of the rock King Lauren
Lannister joined forces with Kingman
Gardner the king of the reach together
with sixty thousand men they met the
Targaryen host in open battle
history tells us that aegon Unleashed
all three of his dragons slaughtering
four thousand men at what came to be
known as the Field of Fire
Kingman himself was burned alive that
day and house Gardener turned to Ash
with him
seeing both the threat and opportunity
the targaryens represented Lauren wisely
surrendered and aided aegon in his
further conquest of Westeros
the Lannisters were thus appointed
Lord's Paramount of the westerlands and
wardens of the West
titles we hold to this day
let us be clear though it is neither
luck nor Royal favor that makes our
house prosperous
there have been times in our history
where some have thought as weak lazy or
opulent
my father Titus Lannister nearly
bankrupted our house with his poor
investment
and allowed himself to be mocked openly
at court
when our vassal the Reigns of Castamere
dared to rise up against the Lannisters
they learned how dangerous it can be to
taunt a lion
I Tywin Lannister led the assault on
Castamere to put down this Rebellion
I made an example of them to anyone who
doubts our might
they even made a quaint song about the
fates of The reigns of Castamere
sadly there are no rains left to hear it
today the Golden Lion of Lannister is
rightly admired and feared throughout
the Seven Kingdoms
our words are
hear me roar
but there are other words that should be
remembered when crossing a lion of
casterly Rock
alanister always pays his debts as I
said for free you can now listen to the
entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which
house of the Dragon is based and which
covers the entire Targaryen history
including current and future events of
House of the Dragon for free with a
notable trial using our Link in the
description